we are getting an American princess
people plus the princes of my heartbeats
yes are on Ellen everybody I hope you
enjoyed the long weekend wherever it was
spent it is so good to be back
especially today because just a couple
weeks ago I told my co-workers that
there is so much depressing stuff in the
news lately
we need a friggin royal wedding and
guess what it is happening that's right
Prince Harry and Megan Marco are
officially engaged and oh my gosh they
are so ridiculously adorable my heart
can't stand it I feel like I know them
now this is such a big deal because for
the first time in more than 60 years a
Hollywood star will become a princess
Megan's royal wedding will happen in the
spring and the couple just sat down for
their first interview as an engaged
couple now in between the very formal
Q&A they actually exchange some really
cute moments like when they described
how Harry popped the question
while roasting the chicken just an
amazing surprise it was so Sweden and
natural and aromantic he got on one knee
yes from you yes as a matter of fact I
could barely let me finish proposing I
say yes I have the ring my finger and I
was like can I give you the Rangers oh
yes the ring so no it was a really nice
moment the two of us and then I think I
managed to catch the catcher by surprise
as well before the interview Harry and
Megan made their first appearance
together as an officially engaged couple
it's also where we got the first look at
her new rock which brings us to their
second cutest moment Harry's thoughtful
design for the ring the ring is is
obviously yellow gold because this one
her favorite and the main stone itself a
sauce from Botswana and the the little
diamonds either side are for my mother's
jury collection to make sure that she's
with us on this on this crazy journey
together and it's beautiful and he
designed it it's incredible yeah yeah
make sure it stays on my finger what do
you think your mother would have thought
of Megan or said about Megan
is there bit circus thieves such a sweet
sentiment from Harry but could we just
say you done good kid good for you
now as for meeting the Queen not only is
Megan's response so genuine there was
also one tell all sign that she had this
whole thing in the bag this have you met
the Queen I have yes yes a lot of times
it's incredible I think you know a to be
able to meet her through his lens not
just with his honor and respect for her
as the monarch but the love that he has
for her as his grandmother all of those
layers have been so important for me is
that when I met her I had such a deep
understanding and of course incredible
respect for being able to have that time
with her and I mean we've had her really
she's she's an incredible woman and the
cool history straightaway I 3 has been
bought out absolutely just laying on my
feet during was very sweet the corgis
got to be a good sign
now this is the first time we've really
seen them interact like this and I gotta
say I am so smitten on these two but
here's a question for you guys where do
you think Prince Harry and Megan Marco
land on John and Christie scale let me
know I haven't decided yet
okay are you guys switching gears now to
our faves
BTS the boys made their daytime debut on
Ellen today and the kpop superstars
proved once again there are some of the
most impressive live performers on this
planet with the special performance of
Mike drum
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm still trying to eat part of the
group they said I could be the eighth
member okay I just keep like studying
their dance moves we'll get it down
eventually
all right the group also sat down with
Ellen and their interpreter was on a
hand but get this apparently some of the
members learn English with the help of
some friends you actually are em you
speak English yes so pretty well you
taught yourself English yes I tell
myself really how did you teach yourself
English um actually my English teacher
was a sitcom friends so it was it mainly
just partly just phrases then or you
just learned everything um I think you
know back in the days like when I was
like 15 14 yeah it was quiet like a
syndrome for all the Korean parents to
make their kids watch the friends really
who know anyone else think jimin's hair
is a couple inches from looking like the
Rachel just me cool all right before we
sign off did you guys see this epic
selfie courtesy of Tiffany Haddish the
girls trip star tweeted this pic with
Barbara friggin Streisand and revealed
she schooled Barb's on rapper cardi B
writing just so y'all know I've taught
my big sister about cardi B today
Tiffany's budding friendship with
Barbara could be more than just a fun
time at a post-thanksgiving hang could
you see these two in a buddy comedy I
don't know but for now how does has a
packed schedule with several movies on
the way including night school with
Kevin Hart all right speaking of cardi B
could the bow dak yellowstar earned her
first Grammy nomination tomorrow the
nominations for the 60th annual Grammy
Awards will be announced tomorrow
morning and I'll be live on e t--'s
twitter breaking it all down with my
girls so Keisha lacy so be sure to catch
us on Twitter live at 10 a.m. Pacific
until then like and share this video
I'll see you guys tomorrow
Congrats Megan and Harry